[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday September 28th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
four three two
what the sounds of success
oh wow as NASA scientists celebrate
crashing a satellite into an asteroid on
purpose
on Monday evening the spacecraft part of
the double asteroid redirection test or
Dart collided with the space Rock to
test whether it could be pushed off its
course
now this asteroid didn't pose a danger
to Earth but scientists were testing the
technology to see if it could be used if
in the future one does the asteroid that
NASA chose was called dimorphos a 525
foot wide Rock orbiting an even bigger
asteroid known as didimos
by measuring the orbit of dimorphos
around didimos scientists hoped to see
that they have changed its path
so when will they know that and what
other lessons are they taking away from
this literal crash test
joining us to discuss this is our
science reporter Island Woodward hi
Island thanks for joining us
thanks so much for having me Zoe so
experts say this asteroid posed no risk
to Earth but the idea was to move it in
case we you know need to move one in the
future and we know it hit but when will
we know if it actually moved the
asteroid so it's going to take weeks for
astronomers on Earth to utilize
observations from ground-based
telescopes so almost 40 telescopes
across seven continents are all looking
right now at the asteroid system where
the dart spacecraft hit and so over the
next weeks astronomers are going to be
trying to calculate the change in
dimorphosis orbit the change in the
orbit of the asteroid that the craft hit
and they can calculate this because
these telescopes see the distant
asteroid
and the one that it is orbiting around
as a single point of light but the
brightness of that light dims ever so
slightly when dimorphous passes in front
of the other asteroid and so the
frequency of that dimming can be
measured so right now they're going to
look at what changed in that frequency
how much are they hoping to move it so
right now it takes dimorphous the
asteroid that got hit about 11 hours and
55 minutes to orbit once around didimos
the larger asteroid and so they hope to
shrink that by minutes and actually one
of the experts I was talking to said
that could change by anywhere from
sevenish minutes to maybe even up to an
hour and the extent of that change
really depends on the properties of the
dimorphous asteroid that scientists
don't really have a great handle on yet
the only images we've had of dimorphous
up to this point have been sort of fuzzy
radar images that were collected almost
decades ago and so the images collected
from the dart spacecraft's onboard
camera before it impacted are really
going to help sort of hone in on those
those composition and density and mass
estimates and then
the European Space Agency is sending
another mission there with the hope of
landing on dimorphis on 2026 and that
mission is going to sort of one help
characterize the impact crater from the
dart spacecraft and then also really
cement the asteroids mass and the reason
why it's really important to sort of
understand all these characteristics
about the asteroid and then understand
how much momentum got transferred and
therefore how much the asteroids orbit
got changed is because it helps
astronomers and scientists hone models
of other asteroid impacts of other
asteroid mitigation scenarios that
aren't necessarily this one so it's
helping our computer models a lot
illustrating you know
asteroid that's millions of miles away
can't be easy how do they ensure that it
got to the right place at the right time
that's a great question impact occurred
seven million miles away from Earth at
that distance using the deep space
Network it takes more than a minute to
get a signal from the spacecraft to
Earth and back and so they had to
develop this autonomous navigational
system they call it smart nav and it's
basically
the craft is searing itself for the last
minutes of its life and the way they
facilitated this is smart nav will lock
on to the dimmer of the two objects that
it sees in its field of view and so it
was extra tricky because
um the spacer couldn't even see
dimorphous until like an hour before
impact for the past weeks it's been
aiming at the single point of life that
represents both didimos and dimorphous
so dimorphous sort of peeked out around
behind didimos around 6 PM yesterday so
about an hour and 15 minutes before
impact and then the scientists had to
tell smart nav okay we have a different
Target in our field of view please lock
onto that one and and head towards that
one so that's why it was so tricky so
what comes next after this success well
I spoke with NASA's planetary defense
officer Lindley Johnson and he told me
that sort of the technology that Dart
has demonstrated this kinetic impactor
technology is just one tool in NASA's
planetary defense Arsenal there are
other technologies that are less mature
that I think perhaps NASA might pivot to
testing out now so one of those is an
ion beam deflector so where they they
fly a spacecraft up close to the
asteroid and they they shoot a bunch of
ion beams at it in the hopes of sort of
altering its course another option
that they're exploring is something
called a gravity tractor where they go
and they Park a spacecraft really close
to the asteroid and the gravity of the
spacecraft affects the gravity of the
asteroid and sort of tugs it along into
a new orbit and then of course
there's also always nuclear deflection
on the table so the idea a little bit
like Armageddon where they they detonate
in the hopes of breaking up the asteroid
and of course this comes with a lot of
issues because you don't want to break
up one big rock into a bunch of tiny
rocks that then hit Earth instead and of
course nuclear fallout is an issue but
the reality is is that many of these
Technologies including the one displayed
in the dart Mission they require 5 10 20
years of heads up
in order to be successful in the nuclear
detonation option does not so another
thing that they're doing really because
they know they need this advanced
warning time is they are working on
setting up a Space Telescope called the
near-earth object surveyor and that
Space Telescope will help astronomers
spot asteroids that have so far been
hidden all right all right that's our
reporter Island Woodward thanks for
joining us Island thank you so much for
having me today Zoe I really appreciate
it and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]